Speaker 2: Yeah, I didn't win this election.
I mean, in my heart of hearts, I
Speaker 3: didn't win, you know,
Unidentified: but you know that, you know,
in Wisconsin, you chose I don't know.
Speaker 3: So without knowing the voters,
you can't even say that.
I just really need all the small changes.
I don't know.
So let me
Speaker 1: give him a lot.
Even throwing in that there was a vote dump.
I mean, even that is pretty, pretty slickly
done because that's a term Trump used massive
dumps of votes.
This is really well done by Lauren.
And that's exactly
Speaker 3: what we've done.
Our economy, laterite priorities.
Unidentified: Prior to this election, I was
the number one.
Just under one point five.
Speaker 3: This U.S. drunk got a million millions
and no one point five million.
He said no enumerator when it comes down to
only one point.
Thank you, guys.
So now for
the first time in history, I can't imagine
beating my vote total by one hundred three
thousand votes collectively, the state assembly
candidate.
Speaker 1: And
just what's notable about this is not only
is Ron Johnson clearly sure that Donald Trump
didn't win, he actually knows historical mathematical
context.
And it's just a reinforcement of the fact
that Adam Kinzinger clearly is right.
99 percent of these guys and gals, they know
all the voter fraud stuff is B.S.
Speaker 3: So we can see so much has got him
some six, six, six or eight congressional
candidates.
He's got to be successful.
So we obviously don't have enough Republicans
who want or need someone to endorse an incumbent
Republican voters who can vote for him.
So the danger here for
Speaker 1: this is as clear as it can be.
So understand the point that Johnson's making
here is this is almost the point I made when
I tweeted.
If they believe that the results for the presidential
are wrong, then the results for their own
congressional and Senate races must also be
wrong.
Right.
And Ron Johnson is saying, listen, the numbers
for the four state reps and all these other
races, the numbers are coherent, the numbers
make sense.
And Trump just lost because 51000 Republicans
didn't vote for him.
It's very simple.
A little more here,
Speaker 2: tell me that Joe Biden wanted to
say thank you guys for coming in, you know,
so I you to see it.
I don't read it
Speaker 3: because you can look at.
Certainly there's nothing obviously obviously
skewed by the has nothing to do with the results.
So I'm not saying we're happy for you, but
Tony, I know
Unidentified: General can collect collectively
in Wisconsin and Georgia in area, and I'm
sure
Speaker 3: you wish you're not his own
Speaker 1: person.
Republican visibly frustrated by people who
insist Trump actually won the election
Speaker 3: when Republicans got one point
six million votes, one thousand more votes
than a good friend of for 20000.
And you've got all the Republicans who voted
for the assembly and he didn't give you a
thousand votes.
This guy turned out right now.
Speaker 1: So it's a very simple case.
The margin was only 20000 in Wisconsin.
All of the numbers make sense in congressional
races, in state races, et cetera.
But there were 51000 Republicans, a small
slice that didn't vote Trump because they
didn't like Trump or they didn't want to vote
for Trump for whatever the case may be.
And that's more than the margin of victory
for Joe Biden.
That's it.
That's all it is.
And this is exactly what Adam Kinzinger told
us.
These guys don't really believe that Trump
won.
I mean, am I sort of surprised Ron Johnson
didn't blame Antifa?
Yeah, maybe.
But it's actually not that, you know, in these
one on one conversations, they will sometimes
or what they believe or one on one conversations,
they will sometimes tell what is actually
the truth.
As soon as you get two people there or you
get a room full of Republicans for a Q&A town
hall, it's time for the whole song and dance.
And we'll listen to what I know is there are
people who claim that their votes weren't
counted correctly and we should be able to
investigate all of that and let the results
fall.
Come on, dude, he knows it and most of these
people know it.
And really nice job there by Lauren Windsor.